our next speaker is a general partner at
Founders fund uh part of the PayPal
Mafia uh CEO of Open Door uh or I'm
sorry the co-founder of Open Door the
CEO of open store and also probably the
single best tweeter on all of Twitter
Keith or boy
single best tweeter over here she's
doing a really good job wrong
um all right I thought a um a great
place to start is just let's jump on the
deep end there was a peace time now it
is wartime uh the market sucks people
are having trouble fundraising people
are trying to figure out hiring product
Market fit like everything to a Founder
feels like it could be going wrong what
changes in operating a company from
peacetime to wartime actually pretty
much nothing should have changed but uh
people are getting a lot of bad advice
um so building a startups really hard my
part my general partner Founders fund
and Trey Stevens has a great expression
it's like those storms hard and
people forgot that um like or maybe
never learned it but fundamentally
there's a three-year window when people
thought that building a startup was
something easy and that normal people
could do it and that's just not true in
the last 50 years of Technology there's
about a six year window when maybe
building a startup to some version of an
accident was possible for normal people
typically it takes someone who has like
heroic efforts heroic intensity heroic
skills to pull people together for five
to ten fifteen years to build a startup
that matters and so a lot of people just
believe that this is an easy industry
it's sort of about as likely that you're
going to build an important iconic
company as like playing the NBA and make
the All-Star team and people thought it
was about the same equivalent as like
maybe making your high school basketball
team so a lot of people just followed
wrong advice now that said the marginal
cost of capital has changed the bra as I
think of capital as oxygen oxygen for
startup oxygen buildings and just like
we go outside we don't really think
about how much air we're breathing
um the the cost of capital was basically
an original cost of effectively close to
zero and now it's expensive and so if we
all were like like to run or something
at Central Park and we were charged you
know ten dollars per breath a lot of
people would have to stop running
outside and that's actually true with
startups is now that the cost of capital
is real it's something you have you
incorporate into your tactics and
strategy when you talk about intensity I
think something I've learned from you
and other people kind of around you
Port the board of directors the
intensity there and kind of just the
ruthlessness of like are we hitting the
numbers are we not are we actually doing
the right thing and spending time
correctly
um Counting the number of days since the
company started right there's all these
kind of little ticks uh trips I'm sorry
uh tricks and tips that you guys have
come up with to kind of keep intensity
going what are some of the things that
you do when you're running the company
that you're like every single founder
should be doing X in order to keep that
intensity throughout the organization
yeah I think the intensity has to come
from the founder and the CEO not really
from the board really what a board
member does is almost like a cartoonish
mirror if you've been in a haunted house
that kind of exaggerates your positives
and exaggerates your negatives and plays
it back to you and say like is this
really what you intend
um and so it's a little bit different in
fact sometimes a good board member can
be a cheerleader when things aren't
going well and the toughest critic the
best time to be a tough critic is
actually what things are going well
because uh you know obviously when
things are mass the founder definitely
do is our mask into adding more stress
on top of a Founder really doesn't help
usually so there's there's a little bit
of counterintuitive nature to a good
board member but they do point out
things that maybe you don't want to hear
or maybe things say you know you have
blind spots too so you can be very
valuable
um but setting the pace is really the
CEO's job and I think it's mostly like
leadership by example the reality is
there's a lot of tactics like we do use
this technique that we borrowed from
ramp of days since launch and every
board meeting sort of has the days since
we started the company it shows you it
talks about time time is not your friend
the whole goal of a startup and kind of
read Hoffman terms is to turn time from
your enemy to your friend so when you're
losing money you're burning money time
is your enemy at some point the engine
works and you have momentum you've
turned inertia into momentum and just
like the physics concept the momentum
actually gets better and better and
better and then time becomes your friend
every day gets easier and the company's
worth more every day so until you've
inverted the laws of physics you
definitely want to be counting and
compressing time and there are tactics
like reminding everybody about these
everyday matters
um you know every hour matters on some
stories talk a little bit about
um another component of time is like
money literally money and time are
almost the same thing in a startup
people also forgot that well if you
could raise as much as you want you know
next week then you're good
um how do you think about sharing that
information with Executives with the
full team you know kind of like
transparency is this great thing but
also if all of a sudden every single
conversation employees want to talk
about like hey we've got two weeks in
the bank it can be distracting and not
have them focus on the product or what
they're doing so how do you think about
just like communicating this with the
employees there's probably nothing
perfect but I think all things being
equally better off the transparent so
you know and there's different tactics
like you know at Square we use this
tactical we literally send notes from
any meeting to the entire company
potentially had conference rooms with
glass walls not uh you know uh whatever
the opposite of the transparent polls
are
um you know basically so people could
see who's meeting with who
um we share all the companies I'm
involved in we share the entire board
back with the entire company like the
first thing I do after a board meeting
is go present the whole for deck uh
unedited uh to the entire company the
only thing we delete which you can
debate is the compensation slide um you
know like Equity grants but even even
that like I think sometimes people
overthink that too of sports teams for
example everybody knows who gets paid
what of the Yankees or whatever and
seems to work
um so I think people have allergies to
that historic world but I'm not sure
they're like legit uh Steve Jobs
actually tried this at next where there
was like two compensation schemes there
was low and high and everybody knew what
everybody was getting paid next didn't
really work so but maybe people like
confused product Market in like
compensation schemes in any event um the
uh so try to be as transparent as
possible the reason why is really driven
from uh Netflix if you looked at
Netflix's culture deck uh the famous 110
you know airport slides which has been
edited on unfortunately but the old one
basically talks about if you want people
to make decisions they have to have
contacts but context really means is
every single employee has the same
information that you have it's really
frustrating sometimes the CEO and people
make stupid decisions and you think
about it well why'd they make a stupid
decision more often than not it's
because they don't have the horizontal
perspective that you have a CEO so you
can't really get annoyed or furious with
your colleagues when they make dumb
decisions because if you haven't shared
them enough data enough information
enough strategy enough thinking of
course they're going to make distorted
decisions so the whole point is you go
on a Cascade decision making down an
organization you want everybody to be
sharper faster you need to give them the
same tools that you have as CEO and so
I'd rather deal with the flip side which
is your right when things aren't going
well
difficult to be transparent that said
people are gossiping anyway like the
reality is in any organization above a
certain size people have concerns they
gossip with their friends they offer
beers Etc and so to some extent if
you're transparent you know what people
are talking about you're feeding them
the real information so it kind of
suppresses like concept and it's
probably better to have a conversation
about the reality than like all the
versions of reality that constantly
fails so usually people will talk about
the best Founders the best companies but
they have like three years of experience
and so you got to kind of you know
weight their advice very lightly you've
been doing this for 25 years which is
impressive well because you're only 21
you've been doing it for 25. I get it
um but but in terms of the uh you know
two decades or something you've been
doing this
what are the common traits of the best
Founders you once said something to me
and I'm so scared to give you uh any
confidence boost but you once said to me
that you've never met a Founder that
went on to build a multi-billion dollar
company and not invest and so you can
have the false positives but how do you
see a founder and know yes it's a scary
concept um because like it's one day I'm
gonna screw up and like just like don't
take any more meetings
there's perverse inside but there is I
mean it's an interesting thing right
it's like it's almost a fighter who gets
knocked out and loses confidence there's
a coherent philosophy around this which
is look
the idea of starting a company is
irrational like the idea that I'm going
to reinvent the world or reinvent an
industry with like my college roommate
in some proverbial garage somewhere is
like borderline crazy International
so if you think about that well who
actually has a shot of achieving
something that's actually borderline
irrational and someone who's pretty
unusual and so the first thing I'm
looking for when I meet somebody or
already know somebody and filtering them
is whether they'd be a great founder is
does this person have a non-zero
probability of changing the world if you
just ask yourself that question like
it's not simple like can this person
like have anything other than a zero
chance of actually Reinventing the
entire Prime
most people by definition it's pretty
easy to pass actually because like the
chance like most people are just not
going to reinvent an industry
um it's true in other fields too if you
met like an athlete and said is this
person going to be the next Steph Curry
pretty easy if that's your actual
question to say no and be right like
almost every single time or is this
person going to be the next you know
kygo in music the answer is no and you
usually can tell if someone has a one to
five percent probability same industry
in politics like people there were
people who knew politics really well
that spotted both Bill Clinton and Obama
very early in their career I like
talking like 20s and they're like this
person will probably be the next
president you know at some point be the
president United States so you can do
this in any field to some extent and so
what I'm usually looking for
specifically for a Founder is some trade
that is like the top one percent or top
10 basis points on some Dimension that
I've never seen and my ears just perk
it's like oh my god I've never seen
anybody like this before like it can be
this is the greatest sales person I've
ever met it can be this is the greatest
smartest person I've ever met it can be
this is the most tenacious person I've
ever met it could be this is the best
person that I'm assessing Talent like
their just ability to evaluate people
there's different dimensions but you're
like wow like you're walking out of that
meeting like oh my God like what just
happened and if you don't feel that
spidey sense for an early stage
investing this isn't true of growth
stage investing like we're talking like
seed round investing maybe series a if
you don't feel that you almost surely
should not
how much of your operating history and
continuing to operate today is
sharpening that ability and then also
being able to understand who the person
is but also what are they trying to
build and like talk a little bit about
investing and operating at the same time
you know honestly I'm not sure that
operating helps that much
um
because what you're hiring for so one
benefit of operating is you meet a lot
of people you interview a lot of people
you get really good muscle
recruiting
that said when you're hiring you're not
aiming for just 10 basis points and any
CEO tells you that everybody in their
company is like top 10 baseboards is
just purely like either stupid or lying
um but Founders you actually are looking
for something like an outlier of like 10
basis points now when you're hiring for
a company therefore it means like you
can use like a middle of the bell curve
kind of assessment technique where
you're trying to figure out where on
Dimensions someone plots on some
distribution curve for founder investing
you kind of want to be an exchange
health and just like in statistics
actually if you're looking for an
extreme tell there are different
statistical formulas you actually use
that when you're trying to look at a
normal distribution
to I think sometimes like the recruiting
process the CEO of History actually
makes them that investors an example
um a tangible one talk about my friends
uh who wasn't there
um so both to the four co-founders Max
and Jeff CEO CEO
um both worked for me at Square they
both played soccer with me before
and when Max was raising money for fair
which is going to be easily a 10 billion
public company
almost everybody passed because at
Square he actually was a bad employee
I actually liked him but like most
people did not so if you called up at
around square and said I'm gonna do
reference checks on this guy named Max
Ridge you would have got pretty mediocre
answers that said almost very few people
asked the real question
um one or two investors were smart
enough to call up like someone like jock
and say hey what do you think about Max
the right way to fair that question is
what do you think about Max as a founder
and if you've done that actually Jack
would probably said he's actually
probably a good founder but the employee
and founder are different things what
were they doing that made them a bad
employee but they wouldn't follow
instructions disagreeable everybody
that's what I didn't mind because like
he was mostly doing things that I found
like useful but like every other
employee in the company was like why
can't you get him to do what he's
supposed to do
this is a charitable interpretation you
know like but that's part of what you're
doing is you're spinning like you're
using you're not from scratch like
building a product using 50 years of
General Motors sales data you're
interpreting interpolating data to tell
a story and he was really good at that
but occasionally people will call him
out on that and we'd have a little
footnotes and vaccinated so a framework
that I have is that once a company is
going you probably could not meet the
founder or the CEO and you could go
spend a day at the business and
understand like this is a well-operated
business or not it's a good business or
it's not so before covid
um roll up oja who runs Sequoia uh
taught me this lesson 15 years ago you
just walk around an office you can tell
everything you need to know so in five
what I learned from that lesson was when
ideally I'd rather go to people's
offices
and have them talk to me about the
company there then have them come to my
office yeah kovich you know totally blew
this Theory up because they bought
multiple offices if they have an office
it's just not the world doesn't work
that way but you used to be able to tell
really quickly like what people what
time are people showing up are they like
focused dialed into their computer or
are they trying to you know about what
time do they leave there's a lot of
little little cues but you really can't
do this that scale anymore so maybe we
can use Mike Shabbat and Chaba as an
example uh we both invested in it you
got to invest more than I did we'll talk
about that later but uh one of the
things that he first said to me when I
met him is he said 996. and so talk a
little bit as to like I almost think I'm
just like that's who you're competing
against as a startup founder and maybe
explain a little bit how you got to know
him and kind of what they're doing yeah
so 996 for those who don't know is kind
of an expression mostly deriven from
Chinese companies that work nine to nine
six days a week
um very very common in China because
it's a pop relatively popular expression
so when Mike was starting his company
which was in the middle right after kind
of coveted overhang a lot of people
bought in to subscribe to startups are
easy we hadn't yet had the correction
um remote work was a thing you know blah
blah blah four-day work we all this
stuff is in The Ether and Mike is like
the antithesis of all these things like
on every Dimension he's like we're doing
996 actually when they really started
they were actually more like 997.
um Mike's my best friend and it's really
hard to be best friends with someone
who's working 997 actually
um but uh like they've dialed it back to
996 in person like now you know maybe
one day a week they like weekends you
might be able to do one day like
remotely but it's 996 in the office
every single every single person every
single day it's very impressive it's not
surprising that the company has done
very well but it is a manifestation of
the personality and the founder Mike is
like this on kind of everything in his
life his looks like non-stop charge
ahead and it's worked the company has
done phenomenally well when you invested
you know it's just two co-founders years
and an idea in a height pretty boring
and fairly competitive industry and
they're really really really doing well
like we just kicked off our new Venture
fund um Founders fund eight and we
wanted to find like the best company in
the portfolio to kick off our new fund
with and we just doubled down on trauba
because it's done phenomenally well
which I think is their culture the
culture has other attributes in this too
it has other differentiated potentially
attributes but like the signature one
initially and to show you how this
manifests out and not accessible
compounds itself
um about four months ago they just uh
Mike just hired this woman who's a great
head of Finance
and I was asking her this question when
I met her I'm like so you know how'd
this work out how did you you know find
how did you wind up in Java and she said
to me well um she was actually like CFO
of a Korean company is doing really
really well and she's like I was looking
for something like 996. and so I I
searched around for an American company
that like had that culture because she's
like this is why the Asian companies
succeed and and she fell in trauma and
she like proactively reached out to them
so he wound up having this great head of
finance and she's done you know
phenomenally well all because the
culture was a positive signal to her and
so it actually you know attracts Talent
when it comes to accumulating Advantage
so what's interesting is they talk about
996 in that company another one of their
kind of core values is Olympic work
ethic and this whole idea of like if you
wanted to be an Olympian you would work
your ass off you would literally obsess
over like becoming the best Olympic
Athlete
um talk a little bit as to the
authenticity though of that business or
other businesses to say here's what our
values are knowing it goes against what
the public narrative is and kind of like
the the ability to have the courage to
use it as a magnet versus you know hey
I'm gonna get a tax for this and maybe I
shouldn't say it yeah I mean it goes it
drives from something Peter Thiel taught
me like 20 years ago which is every
successful startup is a cult like you
have a belief about the world that's
different than other people and you have
a secret if you've read zero to one he
talks about Secrets secret is like we
believe something about the world that
turned out to be true that other people
don't understand or reject so you have
to have that and then when you have a
secret you want to build on that secret
and that's what you do you double down
you build a cult so trauma definitely
isn't home
um they have different dimensions and it
holds just like the phrase in the
connotation it's not for everybody but
you're not trying to hire everybody I
think sometimes Founders forget this I
don't want to hire everybody in the
United States I want to hire a very so
much group and as you complete scales
going from 100 people to a thousand
people to ten thousand people there is a
regression to the mean like you can't
have 10 000 people that look like your
first 10 employees like there is some
you know sort of regression to normal
people but like fundamentally the first
hundred can be extremely unusual uh the
first 500 after 500 there's another kind
of change after 500 but like
fundamentally you can get into the
thousands being very selective about to
hire and so you want to be like kind of
anti-selling so like probably uses this
anti-cell concept which is they're very
explicit about their company values and
the work ethic and all this stuff and if
it's not for you that's great like
there's plenty of things to do in the
world there's plenty of other companies
in the world there's one of the other
Industries in the world but for the
people who want that that created that
they want to be a magnet for that kind
of challenge
you have started multiple companies now
they've been very successful uh
regardless what people on Twitter say
um it's always funny the critics they
never have public companies to yell and
scream about so they have to yell yours
um talk a little bit about your PIN
tweet which is fragmented markets with
low NPS you basically go build kind of a
vertical solution that solves the
problem like for those that are trying
to figure out hey what is my company
gonna do
yeah you know it's actually interesting
that this pin tweet was from like 2017 I
think and I was just sitting on vacation
which is a luxury you have as a VC that
I've ever had as a Founder truthfully
but sitting on vacation and I was
thinking about a constellation Commodore
frame across multiple companies that
I've been involved in maybe some funded
ones and maybe some in The Ether that I
just watched
and they said it just occurred to me as
I was like sitting on this proverbial
Beach
that there's a set of common traits like
a fragmented industry
big square or something like that
there's Merchant processors to the left
to the right I think Uber taxi drivers
or Lyft if you prefer
um tax drivers dot NPS definitely tattoo
drivers turbo MPS Merchant processors
terrible advance
and that if you had a fragmented
industry there's structural reasons why
usually and then B bad MPS means
customers are not delighted if you could
simplify the value proposition stitch
together in a vertically integrated way
which is usually how almost really the
only way to really
simplify is you have to vertically
integrate everything so there are no
sort of loose ends and rough edges
then you could actually succeed and so I
sort of said you know what there's like
10 or so companies I can think of that
are like this maybe there's a common
formula here that people can apply and
so I just tweeted it out and did pretty
well do you still believe it yeah yeah
it definitely works I love vertically
just to start I've always loved word of
integrated businesses
um they are more difficult to build but
they're more successful than they work
think Apple so I'm also a whatever 30 40
year old a 40 year Apple Fanboy and so
to me one of the other lessons of
Technology that's somewhat counter
retreated is Apple's you know the most
successful company
what I learned in any industry when I
was growing up is if you want to be
successful you emulate the people who
are successful so to me it's always been
shocking that most Founders do not
emulate Apple it's like duh like wait
I'd rather be apple than anything else
why am I not trying to replicate what
we're travel
um so anyway so I'm an alcohol Fanboy
forever and apple obviously convertedly
integrated which is the secret there's a
reason why like it doesn't matter what
Google does
not going to affect Apple doesn't really
matter what Microsoft does not gonna
affect Apple it doesn't matter what
Oracle or Salesforce does not gonna
affect Apple because they're not
vertically integrated so they have no
chance to compete it talk a little bit
about Apple as this product company
everyone loves the products
but they also have this amazing
marketing but it almost feels like
they're not marketing and so in the
technology industry tons of people are
focused on like building great products
solve people's problems marketing and
sales where does that come in and like
how important is that early on yeah I
mean so there's a bit of a revisionist
hindsight in apple
um there's a couple good books that I
have actually at home that I'd like to
look through and flip through Apple's
marketing is not really what Propel the
company
um you should go pull these books that
collect every ad there's one book um I
have on my coffee table it's every ad
apples that we were up to like I mean
the book was published probably four
years ago so
and the early ads are pretty ugly
actually and they're very feature driven
like to the company did not get to its
IPO at least using what you think of
Apple marketing today so I wouldn't try
to reverse engineer when you see apple
marketing today as a startup I would go
look at what Apple did when it was like
you know 100 people building a Mac or
something and there's books you can read
there's books that collect the ads so
you sometimes if you try to triangulate
you know what's made a company
successful too late in its Arc you're
going to learn all the wrong lessons
in the beginning it was very very
different the simplification Simplicity
that was in the eyes but it was talked
about in features and not high design
very much Performance Marketing
um but it was trying to distill things
so normal people could do stuff so I was
actually reading something I think on
the plane yeah actually on the plane to
New York yesterday it reminded me of
this example from Apple where the first
use case when uh literally uh Steve and
Steve pitched on Valentine and Sequoia
wrote investment he asked what the use
case would be for a personal commuter
this is probably 1974. right
and Steve Steve actually told on Donald
time that it'd be like a woman at home
uh collecting her recipes
and Don Valentine the very famous VC
very incredibly successful founder of
Sequoia said that's the worst suitcase
I've ever heard nevertheless sister
wrote a check
I mean why do you think you still wrote
the check um I think he well I think he
he thought that they were crazy but like
half brilliant and that is a good
formula uh for potential Founders about
and then the home computer did have some
potential even if they couldn't quite
put the finger on how it would be used
so it's pretty inspired um actually
interesting enough Apple uh Sky actually
sold their shirts and apple way way way
too early so the the proverbial
craziness sort of of Steve like probably
possible Sequoia like billions of
dollars shook them out not that they're
missing the money but
um talk about starting a company and
either not being the CEO or starting off
a CEO and then kind of handing the reins
over someone else as the CEO there's
Founders in here who are not the CEO or
or thinking about kind of going into a
chairman rule things like that like what
are some tips or tricks there well so at
Founders fun we basically only fund
people that we believe are going to be
the long-term CEO of the company like
that's what we call founder fund we
don't believe in higher management
there's a lot of philosophy there behind
that we never we're not allowed to vote
to fire a CEO except cetera et cetera
that said obviously not everybody wants
to be CEO of a company even a great
company forever like you know lots of
people step down Japanese
et cetera so perfectly fine to
transition at some point but we're
really in the business of finding people
who whose aspiration dream is almost
inconceivable like our like our friend
like
I I can't I I actually literally can't
fathom anything that would cause them
not to use I mean maybe if you have like
catastrophic Health stations yeah well
what's so interesting and we're using
this because we've talked about it
recently but um if I ask you how much is
trauba going to be worth what is your
answer oh God so if I don't say a
trillion dollars I'm gonna get shot
um because that's part of their cultural
like dream big ambition
um
but it's a reinforcement right it goes
back to this idea of a cold like
literally every single person from uh an
EA all the way up to the CEO if you ask
them how much of the company can be
worth they say a trillion dollars which
sounds insane and so you're like oh wait
a second these people actually believe
this yeah yeah it is a true call it's a
good example because if you don't
generally people don't exceed their
ambition I guess there's another way to
restate this if you aim here it's not
that calm it's not impossible to exceed
it usually you aim here and you get 85
percent of the way that's pretty good so
I think to some extent but the different
Founders have different styles on this I
I do work with a lot of Founders uh who
would be very opposed to that kind of
philosophy suit there's not a
one-size-fit-all culture that's why each
one is these unique cult like I have a
lot of great Founders who would
criticize that new like completely and
say like look the ultimate evaluation
doesn't matter blah blah blah all we
need to do is focus on our inputs and
inputs will add up to be a great company
and so therefore we shouldn't even
distract ourselves and then what works
for a trial but it works for like is
this big audacious goal that they rally
everybody around and motivate people
either style can work if it's authentic
not to the authenticity point
talk a little bit about monetization and
one of the things that I see Founders
always talking about because they've
read a bunch of blog posts is like don't
turn on monetization until you raise
money right because the second you do
then obviously you're going to be valued
on that how do you when you're talking
to a Founder like does it actually
matter is that good advice well the
first piece of advice is don't read blog
posts you're a Founder you should not be
basically not reading blog post 99.9 the
blog post you're going to read are not
going to be right first of all second of
all you're wasting time they can be
better off recruiting talking to
customers shipping things so just
completely ignore watch sphere is
probably better advice than like reading
any specifically I used to tell people
that literally should like the only
thing I read and talk is to decorate
literally don't read anything else I
will scan Twitter and look for a
particularly random intervention and you
know once in a while I'll listen to a
specific podcast but there's nothing
else I read because nothing else is
worth reading
um I like to read books because books
give you ideas and then you can remix
ideas and that's actually very valuable
but anyway don't get into shotgun now
substantively on modernization
it depends on your business there isn't
this is another problem with blocks but
there isn't a one-size-fits all so if
you're acquiring customers by spending
money then you need to monetize right
away like if I spend called a hundred
dollars on cat to get a user or a
customer then I need to figure out what
that customer is worth really fast
if I happen to be in one of these
businesses let's call an SEO driven
business like think Yelp that gets
customers and users for free actually I
really need to monetize it all because
the more any any monetization strategy
one cent per ax is going to be greater
than zero so as long as your X is
greater than what you're paying it's a
pretty good business it can be a great
business but if you're spending here and
you're only monetizing here that's a
phenomenally bad business and you need
to figure out really fast either how to
get this down here or this up here or
both and so it totally depends
fundraising I see some Founders who
they're price takers and kind of the VCS
run the show and timelines Etc I see
other Founders who are like here's my
timeline I got 100 VCS I'm gonna go talk
to and next you know Thursday we're
signing a term sheet you've been on both
sides what is kind of the best way to
approach fundraising from like a process
standpoint it really depends on the
cards you have
um you know if you have momentum
perceive momentum actual traction no
yellow flags you can control your
destinated process really easily
you know not everybody not even very
good startups have that and usually
there's proof points like
for example I'm told like go back to the
same story uh the trauma Story seed
round couldn't really easily control it
was a very as I said boring industry
it's like light Industrial Staffing
variable labor for like in light
industrial like warehouses
bory industry motion sees don't
understand B there have been several
funded startups directional in a similar
space not the easiest fundraising even
the next one like not so easy so you
can't totally control momentum
this round was a little bit more
preemptive and the metrics should come
together in a way that normal investors
can appreciate the next round will be
easy like he'll be able to dictate the
terms the process blah blah blah so it
depends where you are in your journey
and how much evidence you have
typically you're more taking uh interest
from a VC let me let me uh go to the
first piece of advice never turn down
interest from a DC if you need money and
you decide you want to raise
if you have interest from a senior
person at a good VC fund do not delay
the reason why is VCS are not like a
light switch
you can't like reanimate my interest
very easily if I gone on some other
thing but if I'm like dialed into what
you're doing or you as a person
that is the best possible time to raise
money and then if you want to get
competitive authors you can bring other
people along so once you feel traction
with a senior person of someone you
might want to work with then you can
double down and kind of control the
process and try to synchronize one thing
that is friendly in some ways two
Founders is zoom
it used to be impossible to synchronize
all your fund areas even with the most
momentum like you couldn't get all the
VCS to literally meet you the same week
now I assume there is a reasonable
expectation that if you have five people
you want to meet you just tell them like
I'm raising money I have a term sheet
coming in tomorrow and they will get on
the call within 24 hours the bads the
downsides to that is I'm not sure you
want to raise money if I do like if I
was a Founder if you don't already know
these people I would want to meet the
obnoxious I'm going to spend time with
for the next decade in person and if you
have an unconventional story it's pretty
critical to meet by Zoom like I was just
giving a really good friend uh advice
right now
his stories a little unconventional I
was like stop doing these new meetings
nobody on assuming is gonna get why this
unconventional story makes instrumental
Capital you need to meet in person or
just not meet them
I apologize for getting a little
tactical here but there's two things
that kind of come off of this so there
will be people who raise rounds and then
they have either on announcement or
shortly after it closes more interest I
have seen people open up uncapped notes
and basically say hey we'll take all the
interest we can get get the dollars on
on the balance sheet I've seen other
people say that's a horrible idea and
why would you kind of make decisions
that impact your future without having
all the information what do you think is
best it does depend on the a how much
you raise against like what your goals
are like you raise 80 of what you
thought you needed 120
one two right people that are offering
you money and then three how much
um I think there's a point when you
raise incremental money that you do
crowd out the next round to make the
next round more complicated
so there's some subtle Nuance to this
which is
there are step functions and perception
of how much money you raised against
what traction you need for the next
round there's the next set of investors
what ownership they're probably going to
want so you can't just give a
one-size-fits-all answer to should you
raise more money also a lot of that was
Zero interest you know phenomena there's
not that many people chasing after
companies right now with like a capital
or equivalent term notes and then during
the fundraising process let's say that
Founders fund is really excited
um what is kind of the right practice to
share with other investors that Founders
fund is interested you're talking to
them should you not share who the other
investors are you've raised a lot of
money and it's like what is this kind of
best yeah I think the first thing is I
would never tell another investor that
so-and-so's interested unless they've
basically at least verbally offered you
money
the investor world is very insular and
it's a college interest rate like almost
every single person I compete with for
real is a good friend of mine and so
there's like no secrets and so you're
just ruining it's not true you're just
ruining the chance to raise money from
basically anybody and so that's a bad
idea if it's legit then there's two ways
to play this and I don't care as much as
somebody sees about this
I don't actually mind if people tell
um other investors that were interested
if it's true
I'm like you should be choosing me and
us because you want us and so I don't
really care if you tell other people
like they go crazy whatever
other VCS get very frustrated very
alienated think it's unethical to do
that
personally I don't care but you are
playing with fire with a lot of VCS
um so the way most Founders are kind of
triangle like this is probably they say
something like I've just got an offer
from the top tier fund so they never
name us
but they give like some interest that
you're on a shot clock and time is
scarce that is totally acceptable to
almost anybody yeah
um also top tier fund is a small
groups are a little different and you
you need to back it up though like again
I would not lie if you have a second
tier fund I would not call to talk to
your phone because again I may figure
out who that is and I'd be like oh I
don't trust this founder now and that's
a that's a real problem the last topic I
want to talk about is health and fitness
um you go to Barry's you work out all
the time uh eight sleep you're on the
board still right I'm not in the morning
anymore okay I led the seed in series a
and then we moved over to Founders fund
we reinvested but Trey Steven's my
partner and like led the investment got
it so talk to us about the importance
for you and then also like what is the
best thing these Founders are obviously
ruining their lives right for a number
of years to try to build their company
what do you see as kind of best practice
so let's start um I think there's a
stronger connection between your brain
and your body than most people realize
and there's more and more evidence if
you kind of look under there's more and
more research every year but I just
always believed that your body you're
kind of one person and your body's a
master brain is going to be a massive
vice versa
so I would like prioritize sleep all my
life
getting like ideally eight hours sleep
every day almost every day of my life
and I've found techniques to prioritize
that like I or in my entire schedule
around like sleep I found eight sleep
partially because of this ideology
um kind of a friend of mine who is an
early investor in each sleep sent them
to me like they were kind of the
subscure company that I knew they knew
about and he's like you're the perfect
you're the perfect person for this you
know it's like in fact I am like if you
could boost people's sleep and the
research is pretty compelling about
lowering your age sleep lowers your core
body temperatures your sleep which does
induce better and deeper sleep which is
really really helpful anyway so I've
always believed that the more sleep the
more sleep you have the better up to a
certain point and you're going to
perform better most people did not
really believe this until 2008 there's a
classic study done in the Stanford
basketball team
so for those of you who play basketball
like generally speaking it's really hard
to improve it'll lead athletes
basketball shooting percentage like they
spend you know all all their lives and
try to master like three-point shooting
and free throw shooting and they still
like free throw shooting maybe get to
the 80 percentile 85th percentile 90 of
are awesome and the division March
returns and can't get any better and
then three-point shooting like block
people would do really well they could
improve their three-point shooting by
just three percent three percent three
percent switch anyway so Stanford
basketball went through the sleep study
where they put players on the team now
the timestamper was a good basketball
team
um like definitely top 20 kind of team
they put players on three regiments six
hours eight hours and nine hours sleep
the the difference the eight hour plus
people literally improve their shooting
percentage by 10 percent
like that's insane like you could
literally take a basketball player and
train for 20 years and not get 10 points
to improve it so as soon as you read
that study we're like holy cow like 98
hours sleep like right now and so that's
basically what I think sleep became more
popularized there's another great book
that Matthew Walker wrote about sleep
which also popularized the importance of
sleep on cognitive behavior and
cognitive performance
so if you care about your life the best
thing you can do if you want to be
healthy wealthy happy
is actually sleep more and so that's the
first step
other Fitness stuff I do is a mix of
like there's some life extension
benefits to do certain kinds of training
there's a lot of now evidence that you
know muscle mass predicts like your
lifespan or at least your Healthy
lifespan better than other things
but it you know it's a mix of fun and
vanity and for me on the fitness side I
am obsessive about like tools like this
you know the chocolate and I compete
with my friends on this like I get
notifications all day long and we go
back and forth and you know it's our
Dynamics social dynamics they're kind of
cool about it but sleep is indispensable
the workout stuff is more and more
research on it
but it's kind of also a hobby
last two questions what's your resting
heart rate uh 41 or 42. he literally
knows yeah generally that's pretty good
it's lower than your age it's pretty
obsessive about it uh the second thing
is uh food like obviously working out
sleeping that's all great what about
kind of diet and there's all kinds of
fads Founders are always doing all kinds
of crazy stuff
I wish there was more Innovation let's
start with the founder side first I do
wish there was more Innovation here like
you could work out all you want but like
ultimately nutrition and how you eat and
all that stuff is going to be 70 to 80
of the results and both visually like
aesthetically and also health-wise but
there's not really a startup that has
succeeded
in putting you on autopilot to improve
your like nutrition I it's complicated
obviously Soylent I guess correctly like
I wish there was a product I could use
that intuitively would just track
whatever consuming and then giving
metrics like my sleep gives me about
sharks or this watch because we're not
sure it's on workouts
there's nothing out there that's you
know like simple enough for normal
people to use so I think there's a lot
of room there someone will practice code
secondly I think that most things
simple advice is better just a high
protein diet is probably good for most
people like low relatively low carbs you
can take it to the extremes and stuff
depending on how much you want to chew
but fundamentally basic blocking
tackling like eating the right amount
you know no processed foods
mostly protein is going to be generally
good for most people but someone should
innovate this you know others to mention
one of the things one of the ways I
learned this though 13 years ago when I
was taking what's described as a Keith
vacation I went to trade with Elite
athletes for a week in this facility
called exos and this is literally like a
vacation for me they make your food for
you three times a meal for every athlete
that trains there most people want to
play in the NFL that go there and some
World Cup soccer teams and so they have
a nutritionist who comes up with your
program which is how many calories what
mix of carbs and protein for your gold
but what and then the chefs make you
your meals every day that have the right
composition like our friend dully and
for example went on one of these
programs my partner Founders what would
be it went in a couple actually with me
and the first time he was trying to eat
a full banana and they took half of it
away
wow figure it's hysterical because of
the time Deli weighed like 135 pounds
it's like the skinny guy and they're
like nope half a banana for you
what is your reporting message to
everyone here who's starting a company
and kind of the ambition and just going
for it you've seen some of the most
iconic companies in Silicon Valley over
the last 20 25 years
um you understand what the common traits
are of great companies and great
Founders somebody's starting out like
what's the advice that you give them to
kind of motivate them
I think the most important thing is to
figure out what your comparative
advantage is like look at yourself like
how do you want to compete against the
rest of the world in in your other side
of your world like what's your Alpha you
know like what is your differentiation
in double and triple down on it and then
that will lead you to certain markets or
certain products it'll also help you
figure out who to complement yourself
with but it's like really figuring out
so I'll give you a technique since there
are popular in the audience some people
know like but they're super proverbial
superpower is other people don't I'll
give you a technique that works for all
of you go to your five favorite people
um friends and your five people who like
you most professionally
an Ask of a simple costume with a little
notebook in your hand like what do you
like most about me just write down the
words don't think about it just write
down the words write down the word you
will find common descriptions and that's
your superpower
um it's really good because like asking
people for your weaknesses does not work
well if you let alone tell you what your
weaknesses are typically ask what your
strengths are people are pretty happy
you know to flatter you but just write
down the words like verbatim then after
you've done this exercise with about 10
people look for common characteristics
in the word umbrella kind of thing and
that would be your superpower
ladies and gentlemen keep your boy
thank you